so norm ik Donald the comedian or
McDonald is the latest to end up getting
trampled by the pitchfork mob and this
was I mean this was inevitable this was
gonna happen with or McDonald because
he's known for being irreverent and
politically incorrect and all that and
also he's got a Netflix show coming out
so he's been he has poked his head up
above everybody else and made himself
visible and once you do that then
they're gonna come after you and try to
beat you back down that's the way it
goes so so his his his appearance on The
Tonight Show was canceled a couple
nights ago amid outcry over some
comments that he made comments that
allegedly minimized sexual assault and
racism and supposedly these con will
read the comments T in a minute but his
comments were so terrible that they made
some producers on The Tonight Show cry
the Jimmy Fallon came in two before he
before they're about to go on air and
said you know my producers are in tears
and now I can't these were comments that
Norma Donald made to The Hollywood
Reporter he was giving an interview with
The Hollywood Reporter I can't imagine
reading an interview in The Hollywood
Reporter with a comedian and weeping I
can't imagine anything I mean literally
I cannot think of a single thing a
comedian in The Hollywood Reporter could
say that would make me weep I just can't
imagine what that would be but that's
what happened so the appearance was
canceled and then and then you know
there been a lot of hot takes in the
media explaining why or McDonald's
comments were problematic and
symptomatic and blah blah blah blah blah
so let me I think of everything that he
said in the interview here are the two
segments that have gotten all the
attention and our supposedly
controversial I read them through you
says he says I'm happy the me2 movement
has slowed down a little bit
it used to be 100 women can't be lying
and then it became one woman can't lie
and that became I believe all women and
then you're like what
that chris hardwick guy I really thought
he got the blood the blunt end of the
stick there and then a little bit later
on he says well Lois CK and Roseanne are
the two people I know and Roseanne was
so broken up that I got Louie to call
her even though Roseanne was very hard
on the we before that but she was just
so broken and just crying constantly
there are very few people that have gone
through what they have losing everything
in a day
of course people will go what about the
victims but you know what the victims
didn't have to go through that
okay
now let's just let's just say first and
foremost here that the outrage is
ridiculous because he's not wrong about
what he said is he
where it what's the what What did he say
that was wrong
what's he wrong about and I know that
doesn't matter anymore it doesn't matter
with the with the outraged culture it
doesn't even matter if what you said is
true people will say yeah it doesn't
matter if it's true you shouldn't have
said it anyway it's hurtful
it hurts people people might be hurt by
the truth so you shouldn't say it
but I think it does matter it does
matter whether it if something is true
if it's a valid point then there's no
reason to be upset about it
so um where is the wrong part What did
he say that was wrong let's go through
this let's go through this one more time
let's go through it again
and and try to find the wrongness
because I didn't see it I didn't see it
at first blush I couldn't find it but
let's go through it again
he says I'm happy too me too movement is
slowed down a little bit used to be 100
women can't be long then it became one
woman can't lie and that became I
believe all women so okay is he wrong
there that is the trajectory right that
is how it's gone it used to be that you
have a bunch of women accusing a guy and
then we would say well look all these
women are it doesn't make any sense to
say that they're all lying
it's either the guy is lying or 12 or 15
women are lying and it just doesn't make
any sense to assume that all those women
are lying in the guys telling sure so
you know that that's how it used to be
and that but then it became and and norm
is right about them then it became well
if one woman accuses a guy that we
automatically have to believe the woman
we cannot even consider the possibility
that maybe she's the liar and he's
telling the truth can't even consider
and then that became the and this is the
mantra of the mewtwo movement and a
feminist but I believe women believe
women what kind of statement is that
believe women so I I have to believe
whatever a woman tells me because she's
a woman like a woman can never lie is
that what you're telling me of course
that's crazy so he's right there he's
right to criticize that and then he says
Chris Hardwick got the blunt end of the
stick what's wrong with that he did get
the blunt end of the stick
Chris Hardwick was accused in a blog
post that he is a he never even was
mentioned by name I don't think he was I
got it was an anonymous accusation in a
blog post by one person and he was never
even accused of doing anything criminal
he was basically accused of being a bad
boyfriend and and there was no evidence
or you know there was note and nobody
corroborating it in fact a bunch of
people came out in defense of Chris
Hardwick including women who knew him
former girlfriends and current
girlfriend and whatever and they came
out and said no that's not the guy I
know that's that I don't believe
so and yet he still suffered
consequences for that in his career and
his reputation that's not fair
what why should that have any weight was
it because one person writes a blog post
you know detailing things from from
allegedly from your private life and
we're supposed to believe that it should
it should have no weight whatsoever
right if it's one person verse another
person and everyone that's come out is
on the side of the other of the accused
then that has no weight um and then he
says you know expresses some sympathy
for Luke for Louie CK and Roseanne who
are who are his friends is he wrong for
having sympathy for them they're his
friends was he supposed to say oh yeah
they're my friends with their total
scumbags I hope that I'm glad their
lives or Road I hope they die is that
what he's supposed to say I guess that's
what he's supposed to say is that what
you would say about your friend if your
friend did a bad thing and was you know
this was their their career was ruined
and their lives were in shatters because
of it would you then come out in the
media and jump on the dog pile know if
you would then your terrible friend
feel sorry for your friends in that case
so he's just being a good friend here
the only part of this that could even be
considered halfway controversial is
where he says of course he says they
lost everything in a day people will go
what about the victims you know what the
victims didn't have to go through that
okay again is he wrong
he's right that wrote Roseann and louis
c.k did lose everything I mean they were
Rosanna had the number one show on TV
she lost it I mean she was having this
resurgence in her career that was taken
away from louis c.k was this you know
considered this comedic genius and he
was award-winning critically acclaimed
popular I mean he had everything he was
popular and he had critical acclaim
which is really hard to do especially in
comedy and he had all of that and then
all of that went away now he's a
disgrace and he was a punchline and he
lost everything now whether or not you
think that they deserve that it is true
that that happened to them and it's also
true that if you're a friend of those
people I think you would have some
sympathy for that
and then his other claim is that well
that's not what happened to the victims
okay well first of all who was
Roseanne's victim she wrote a mean tweet
about Valerie Jarrett is Valerie Jarrett
a victim if that makes you a victim that
I am then I myself am a huge victim
because people write mean things about
me online all the time
but regardless did Valerie Jarrett lose
everything was her whole life destroyed
because Rosanna wrote it me tweet about
her no I don't think so
um and then louis c.k i he he sexually
harassed several women a parent he
doesn't even deny it so we you know we
don't even have to say allegedly he did
do it as far as i know like i don't like
reading all the the gruesome details of
these things because it's just it's not
you know i don't think i need to know it
but from my understanding of the Louie
CK situation is that he exposed himself
and pleasured himself in front of an in
front of several women but as the story
goes as far as I know he would ask them
is it okay if I
fells myself and then they would say yes
and then he would do it but then now
they're saying well you know I I said
yes but I thought he was joking they
know he'd actually do it and I wanted to
leave the room ABC it was very
uncomfortable or he was like in the way
of the doors you know and and in
regardless it's obviously it's creepy
and disgusting for Louise okay that's
just that's even if you ask that's just
not a question that you asked some
strange woman or you know some
acquaintances you don't you just it's
just it's it is not an appropriate
question to ask right but
what nor McDonald is saying is well
these women yes it was wrong what Louisa
K did were their lives destroyed though
I mean was the whole course of their
life ruined because of this incident are
their lives left in ruins and tatters
because of this because of louis c.k
exposing himself
you could make the argument that no
probably not
so that's all you know that that was
this only point I think it's a valid
point it's not a crazy point is it it's
not crazed not insane
it's valid
it does raise questions about
proportionality
you know even when someone does
something disgusting and wrong and then
their whole life is destroyed like is
that proportionate and so that's it's a
discussion that we can have why can't we
talk about that and here's the greater
point I want to make you see here why
it's impossible it's impossible to talk
about anything in America anymore we
can't have discussions we can't have
debates because if you commit the crime
of giving a unique perspective in public
people will seize hold of it and sift
through it looking for what were the one
or two most controversial sentences and
then they'll divorce those sentences
from their context and search
desperately for the most uncharitable
possible interpretation to ruin you with
it and there's no attempt to understand
the actual point that you were trying to
make no one no attempt to understand
what was said there's no engagement no
discourse speech is treated like this
game with arbitrary rules and who what
whoever breaks the rules will be
punished regardless of intent
it's insane what we do now
the way that we totally disregard intent
is maybe the most remarkable aspect of
this and it's because it happens all the
time that somebody will say something
and then the outraged mob will take it
and they will find the most outrageous
possible interpretation and so with
something like this like when we're
talking about sexual assault sexual
harassment the me2 movement anybody who
tries to find a nuanced perspective or
anyone who even hints that possibly in
some of these cases the penalties have
been disproportionate to the to the
offense committed anyone who even begins
to sort of make that point will be
accused of defending sexual harassment
or being an apologist for rape right
that which is which is the most
outrageous possible interpretation of
what they actually said
but then but then what happens is so
the outraged mom comes and they'll say
we're offended because we think that you
meant XYZ okay we think that you meant
that it's okay to sexually assault and
harass people that's how we took it and
then the person will go no that's not
what I meant
it's not what I meant no I'm totally of
course I'm totally opposed to sexual
assault and harassment I think what they
did is terrible I'm just trying to raise
another question so that we could talk
about this
but now that right there that should end
it that should be the end of the
controversy that should be it because he
just told you what he meant you were
wrong you misinterpreted it and so he's
telling you what he actually meant and
he knows what he meant he is the only
authority over what he meant not you him
he's the one who said it he's in his
mind he knows what he meant he's telling
you what he meant that should be it
there's once with when someone says
something
and you interpret it in a way that makes
the comment offensive
and then he says to you know that's I
didn't mean it in that offensive way I
meant it in this way that should be it
you have no basis now to continue being
offended he has taken it from you if you
continue being offended it's because you
want to be offended and you don't even
care what he said so you're a liar and
you are disingenuous because it just
doesn't make any sense when someone
clarifies what them it doesn't make any
sense for you to go yeah well I'm gonna
stick with my original interpretation of
your words I don't care what you think
you meant I'm gonna go with what I think
you meant because I know more about what
you meant then you know about what you
meant that doesn't make any sense but as
I said it's all a game nobody wants to
actually talk about anything because
everybody's just laying traps and
claiming trophies and that's it
that's the way it works here's how it
works every topic every issue is a or B
now that's the way it works America it's
a or B and so the mindless masses on
both sides that that's how they see they
see it as an A or B thing every issue
whatever the issue is a or B those are
the you know if you're in the mindless
masses on either side you're looking at
as you can have a position or B position
and that's it that's it that's all
that's allowed
and but the real problem and here's it
with understand this okay about about
the way the way this works for both
sides okay
they see their own position as the a
position and the other side is the B
position and the B position is always
going to be a caricature it's not a real
position it's a caricature of a position
but the real problem is that the a or b
dynamic is applied to every issue which
means that nobody is allowed to find
something in between a and B or nobody's
allowed to go and you know take a little
from column a a little bit from column B
and say you know I can see I can see
what they mean on this side I could see
what they mean I think they both
available they're not allowed to do that
and certainly nobody's allowed to come
with a C position or a G position god
forbid a Y or a Z position
you know god forbid someone really
literate legitimately comes from from
left field and and and and says
something that's way outside of that
paradigm completely if you do that
you're just gonna be devoured nobody's
even gonna begin to listen to you so we
have here what we have here is what I
have been going for a long time is the
it is the death of nuance it is the
death of subtlety it's the death of
distinction
it is
more to the point it is the death of
interesting ideas
because every position has to be
something that you can summarize in one
sentence
and the other side if they don't hear
that their sentence repeated back to
them they'll just descend on you and rip
you to shreds
that's all that's what a discussion is
supposed to be they each side they have
their sentence they have their sentence
their position and they just want to
hear their sentence setback to them
and if they don't hear it then
then you're in trouble
both sides do this by the way it's not
just a liberal thing I hate to tell you
it this is not this is not like liberals
do this and but conservatives are
intelligent and are always Milland
nuanced and they're always looking for
the interesting but no that's not maybe
it used to be kind of how it goes that's
not how it goes anymore now for liberals
let's just take an example of how this
works let's use the example we've been
using so far when you take an issue like
me to
the way they approach it is that
everyone must take the position that all
accusations are true every accused man
is a scumbag who should die whatever
penalty he's suffering is fair no matter
how severe every victim has been
irreparably and profoundly harmed and
traumatized okay
no consideration whatsoever should be
given to the men innocent or not and
especially if the man is guilty you're
not allowed to have any sympathy at all
for him none
um that's the that's their position you
know that I'm not that's not a
caricature of their position that is
really their position as I said that you
know but believe women that's the that's
their sell-by slogan that's their slogan
which is an absolute statement believe
women if a woman says it believer that's
really their position and it's for them
it's the only acceptable any differing
position will be put into the B camp
so that's a camp for them that's right
if you say something different you're in
B camp and B for them is the position
that sexual abuse is good and all women
are liars okay that for them is B
position now here's the problem nobody
actually holds that position nobody's
saying that I've never heard anyone say
that that is not a position that anyone
holds that position doesn't exist in
real life
but they have created it and anyone who
fails to pair it their opinions back to
them on this issue will be thrown into B
camp so if you try to say yes sexual
harassment sexual assault terrible
things we got to root those out we've
got however you know as soon as you
start to however they won't even listen
to the rest of your sentence they're
throwing you in the B camp if you say
yeah there's a sexual abuse problem but
it's also true that women lie sometimes
we have to account for nope you're going
in B doesn't matter stop right there
you're in B or if you say yeah you know
these men they've done a terrible thing
but not all forms of harassment are the
same are the same in terms of degree in
severity so maybe they don't all
necessarily deserve to have their lives
completely destroyed for it and maybe
nope you're going in B doesn't stop
right there you're going and B I don't
even want to hear the rest of it and
that's the way it goes
now the right does this too and I know a
lot of people listening to this and
watching this right now this is the part
you don't want to hear you've been
really you've been with me so far
now you don't want to hear the rest of
this and if you're like if you're
thinking right now you're and you're in
and now you're getting upset because I'm
- well then you're part of the problem
okay because the the right does do this
and take it from me okay let's let's
take one example for many people on the
right
when it comes to Donald Trump there are
only two positions their position the
one that they take is that this is the a
position for them it's that Donald Trump
is a genius and a hero and he is saving
the world okay again that is not a
caricature that is an actual position
not only in actual that is the position
that is the kind of mainstream
right-wing position
and
and you know this comparing Donald Trump
to biblical heroes like King David I
didn't invent that that's what people
actually say comparing him that we
really making him in this messianic
figure who saved America from the edge
of destruction okay that in that is the
a position that's the position of take
and the then there's the B position okay
that's everything else and if you're in
the B position that means that you're a
liberal and you hate America okay so if
you
you try to offer any criticism of Trump
at all
in any situation for any reason you're
gonna be thrown into B camp the I know
what I'm talking about this happens to
me all the time
I have been told so many times if any
time I mean any time I offer any
criticism of Trump and I say you know I
think he's wrong on this one or I think
he should have done this but instead of
doing that or you know really I think
tweeting like a twelve-year-old girl all
the time is maybe not becoming for a
president and maybe he should stop it if
I if I it was any time I say that all
that people say well you're a liberal
what are you some kind of Lib you Lib
[ __ ] yeah and you hate America this is
what I'm told me a liberal I wrote a
book called the unholy trinity about
transgenderism abortion and gay marriage
calling that the unholy trinity that's a
book that I wrote and I am a liberal
because I don't like Donald Trump's
tweets this is the mentality that people
actually have it's a and it's not just a
few people a lot of people so
distinctions nuances opposing ideas
these really are not accepted by either
side anymore they don't want to hear it
I can't tell you how many times I mean
it's a daily occurrence then all venture
outside of the accepted mainstream
conservative paradigm on some random
issue whether it's Donald Trump or
anything else and then I'll have people
tell me I mean this happens like I said
it's a daily occurrence that someone
will say to me you know I've read your
stuff for years I've been a fan for five
years I'm done you're unfollowed I'm not
following you anymore because of your
position on this one single topic
it happen to me just the other day when
I the other day I iced and I've said
this before but um the other day I
suggested
that our reaction to the anthem kneelers
okay maybe is a little bit overblown
like maybe it's time to move on and
right now in the NFL there are like one
or two guys on any given Sunday you're
gonna have a sow over a thousand NFL
players on fields across you know
America embarrassed it
and you might now find one two maybe
three players out of a thousand who are
kneeling so that to me is it's not an
issue it two or three guys out of a
thousand who cares
let who cares what they're doing I mean
do we really need every single last
person - so you're gonna but we're to
boycott the NFL until every single last
person associated has the correct
posture during the anthem I just find
that to be a just it's a it's ridicu no
I'm not I'm not - I'm not agreeing with
them it's not an agreement I'm so
there's a slight nuance it's I agree I
don't like the anthem protest however
yet as soon as I attack that however on
that's when people - and I just the
other day people told me they're done
following me because of that that if
it's actually true that they've been
followed so think about that I've been
reading your stuff for five years I
respect your opinion I've been with you
you have ventured away from me on this
one slight issue and so I'm done
mentality is so shockingly small-minded
and narrow and ridiculous but it's how
people function and this is why there
can't be any discussion in America
because people on both sides they simply
don't want to hear any divergent opinion
at all now you know what's the worst
thing about all this
the worst thing is that it's so boring
it makes our discussions in this country
so helplessly awfully boring because
nobody's allowed to be interesting no
one's allowed to make an interesting
point no one's allowed to be challenging
no one's allowed to come out of left
field with something nobody's allowed to
introduce a thoughtful nuance to a
discussion and therefore develop the
discussion a little bit like with the
anthem thing yes we've all heard for
three years now we've heard the standard
conservative stand for the anthem yeah I
get it fine I mean how many times we
have to say that can we develop the
discussion and talk about something else
related to it that's a little bit more
interesting do we really have an
insatiable appetite to hear our one
sentence thought on this topic repeated
to us over and over again for three
years is that what we need
but we're not.we that's just it's not
allowed and the effect is the collective
stupefying of America the people are and
the people who are leading the
discussion the people who have platforms
that are you know in this in this
country the people in the media you know
they contribute to the problem because
they know that this is the dynamic and
so they know they're not going to get
away with a nuanced position they know
they're not going to get away with
challenging their own side and so what
they do is they just they they that for
every position they think of the most of
the most simple simplified perspective
and they just keep repeating it over and
over and over and over and over again
why is this happened I mean why is it
gotten to this point well I think there
are a lot of explanations number one
just intellectually people are
intellectually lazy they don't they
don't want to apply their brain to
anything number two I think people are
you know it's a little bit of a
cowardice people don't want to be
challenged they're afraid that if they
allow their position their opinion to be
challenged that they may find out
they're wrong about something and if
they're wrong about this then maybe
they're wrong about that and that and
then and the whole house of cards comes
tumbling down people are afraid of that
so they don't want to hear it and number
three I also think this goes to the
intellectual laziness so it's not really
a third thing goes back to number one
but it people don't people don't read
you know we're so used to the you know
we we're so used to little soundbites
and having everything packaged for us
the most entertaining and simplified way
and and people don't you know if
people don't read whole book saying you
know if you're in the habit of reading
whole books like actually it whole
chapters and everything then you're
going to have more patience
for someone to express an idea that
takes more than one sentence to explain
but most people don't read books so they
don't have the patience for that maybe
they don't have the ability anymore to
understand
an idea that takes more than one
sentence to explain and so that's the
problem
now two other quick points
people say that I'm guilty of this right
don't deny it I'm not saying that I'm
innocent that uh you know whatever maybe
I'm a hundred percent guilty on with all
this stuff I mean doesn't mean I'm wrong
okay so you could doesn't matter I'm not
saying I'm innocent but let me also just
add that there are two types of black
and white thinking okay
and I'm accused of being a black and
white thinker all the time
but there there's the bad kind of
black-and-white thinking and then
there's the good kind okay and maybe I'm
guilty maybe I do both okay but what
I've been talking about here is the bad
type of black and white think the black
and white thinking that does is not
interested in nuance is not interested
in subtlety is not interested in any
kind of distinction whatsoever and which
just wants to hear its own ideas parotid
back to it as simplified as stupefied as
possible okay so that's the bad kind of
lack of more thing but then there's
another black and white type of thinking
where you have firm fundamental
principles which you do not compromise
on and which you will not look for any
gray area on and then and then so for me
a fundamental principle is that human
beings have Worth and dignity okay
that's a fundamental principle that I
have and it's right I will I will not
accept on black and white I won't accept
any gray area on that I think every
human being who exists has Worth and
dignity period okay no gray area so on
that you can accuse me a black and white
thinking but then the interesting thing
is to take that black and white
principle and apply it to figure out how
it applies to various different
situations and so that's where you can
have some really interesting discussions
now with something like abortion I think
it applies very simply abortion is a
terrible evil period and discussion
something like capital punishment well
now here's an interesting way of thick
because you can make an argument on
either end you've got you've got the
firm fundamental principle okay that
that's black and white no gray area but
now you're injecting it into this very
complicated subject where you can make
an argument
that it that it could lead you in either
direction and so that's interesting
right so so so being black and white on
principles that does not negate or
interfere with nuanced and interesting
discussions in fact I think I think
being black and white on principle is
necessary to have nuanced and
interesting discussions
because that's part of the problem here
is that people are very black and white
on the superficial talking point level
like on the surface level people are
black and white but when it comes to the
principles underneath that people have
no idea what they believe they don't
have firm principles all they have is
the conclusion they have no idea what
principles actually inform those
conclusions so it's exactly reversed
but when your firm on your principles
and you know what they are and you're
talking to someone who's firm in their
principles that's when you're gonna have
super interesting you like with my
family okay you know you should you know
when I get together with my family
uh we will have the most knock-down
drag-out debates you can imagine not
literally knocked out J although it's
come close to blows a few times but you
know we just have really passionate
debates okay and yeah they'll be
screaming and shouting and everything
right it gets it gets crazy even though
we agree on we agree on almost
everything when it comes to the to the
fundamental principles
you know we're all Christian we all
believe God we're all conservative you
know we're all super ultra conservative
all of us yet we have these intense
debates and I think those debates are
possible because we agree we're talking
the same language we agree on the
principles so we could kind of get past
that and then we can have super
interesting discussions about how do we
apply those principles to this situation
and I think that's a that's such a
fascinating conversation to have
and that's why among conservatives we
should be able to have really
interesting debates among ourselves
because supposedly we agree on the
principles and we should be able to have
no it's harder to have these nuanced
discussions with someone when you don't
share any of the any fundamental values
whatsoever it's another thing that
interferes with the disco you know the
debate between one of the reasons why
the debates between conservatives and
liberals are so fruitless is that we
don't we don't have any common ground we
don't share the same language we don't
have any of the same presuppositions or
anything like that so there's there's no
basis there's no grass solid ground upon
which to stage this conversation so that
every discussion ends up devolving back
down into like is there a god right
but among conservatives because we
supposedly agree most of us on the
fundamentals we should be able to have
really interesting conversations but and
I think there was a time in conservative
conservatism when when that when that
when that did happen and there was this
really intense
edifying mentally strengthening
debate within conservatism on various
issues that's not how it goes anymore
because most people even among
conservatives they just they don't want
to hear they have their a position one
sentence on every issue
that's all they want to hear all they
want to hear from you is that you agree
with it
all right
going on for a while now hey even this
I mean go
for 35 minutes about the same topic
people
all the time like what you know the
videos are too long what what you why
don't you talk about multiple topics in
a video like who wants to hear a
30-minute conversation about the same
topic
maybe nobody wants to hear it I don't
know but to me that's I think that's
interesting we should be able to spend
30 minutes we should be able to spend
three hours on just one topic getting
into all the nuances of it
you only hear that
all the Facebook you know you see all
these conservative Facebook stars and
you know they they develop this huge
following by putting out like two-minute
videos on on some issue how could you
possibly say anything interesting or
worthwhile in two minutes it's not
enough time yet people love it they just
want it they want to hear the two-minute
um you know a few sentences two minutes
repeating their own ideas back to them
so they can share it and say Amen
oh yeah that's yes you tell it like it
is
Wow
that person didn't say anything what do
you mean Wow didn't say anything
interesting
did they really say something that made
you like think differently about this
issue did they really enlighten you
anyway just gonna leave it at that
thanks for listening everybody thanks
for watching
Godspeed